- You've got a Park's text chain going
and we have one with The Voice.
Like we always kind of
switch it up when the,
yeah, with the coaches.
So I'm wondering like,
how's your text chain going?
- That's so funny you
have a Voice text chain.
Yeah, we've, the cast of Parks and Rec
are still really close
and, and keep in touch.
In fact, we just this month
celebrated a bunch of birthdays,
with a bunch of people, you
know, remotely of course
including my, my beautiful
wife, Rashida Jones,
but yeah, we try to check in
and see how everyone's doing
and just like anyone we've just been,
you know trying to be there for each other
during very lonely times,
but that family is,
that family is so special to me
and the fact that we all,
you know, really genuinely
love each other is so great.
And however, I do want to
get on your Voice group chat
because that is fascinating to me.
- Well, I'm gonna be honest with you,
my assistant the other day brought up,
she was like, I hope these never get out.
(laughing)